et auteur demandait en martinique un
tournage est toujours un événement pour
cette fiction contemporaine l'équipe se
déplace avec une trentaine de
techniciens six acteurs et une quinzaine
de figuerolles l'histoire vue à travers
les yeux d'un enfant évoque le comte
antillais de l'anti cri un monstre qui
enlèverait l'aîné des fratries
c'est en fait l'histoire d'un petit
garçon qui s'imaginent qu'il ya un
monstre dans son jardin qu'elle l'anti
cri est en fait il se met en tête de
vouloir l'attaqué pour défendre sa
famille est habituellement il a
l'habitude de jouer avec dorian à
combattre des monstres mais là d'orient
est tellement préoccupé par son départ
qui aura lieu dans deux jours qu'il
n'est pas là pour l'aider et donc en
fait ce monstre est un peu la métaphore
du déni du départ de ce petit garçon de
9 ans et on raconte les hauts revenus
ont fait entre deux frères avec le côté
fantastique qui apporte le côté conte
jean claude duverger qui n'avait plus
tourné depuis trente degrés couleurs en
2012 se réjouit de retrouver une équipe
de cinéma ici en terre martiniquaise
c'est très rare qu'il y ait des films
ici à l'oc de plus en plus nous avons
des techniciennes nous avons des acteurs
et tout cela donc dans la réalité non je
trouve que l'on ne produit pas assez
malgré des efforts il ya de plus en plus
de jeunes réalisateurs qui arrivent et
les jeunes producteurs
on voit qu'il y a du talent et puis
après ça meurt le talent est là mais
s'il n'y a pas de continuité même ce
petit garçon qui est très agréable très
intelligent et puis très bon joueur très
bon acteur
quand est-ce qu'il va tourner un autre
film on ne sait pas à l'action
ryan petits veaux cli noix de cm2 fait
ses premières classes devant l'objectif
est ce que c'est une révélation pour
thoiras tournage
je te demande de faire c'est très
compliqué il faut être très patient il
faut faire des aînés leur offre mais
j'ai aussi compliqué tu aimerais
retourner un film après oui mais alors
que la guadeloupe accueille de
nombreuses productions notre île
toujours dépourvues de bureau des
tournages n'est pas organisée pour
promouvoir ses artistes et ses
techniciens et ses nombreux lieux de
tournage potentiels sont vraiment très
conscience en guadeloupe que l'industrie
du cinéma était une réelle industrie en
martinique ça a pris beaucoup plus de
temps
les choses se sont faites ils ont créé
un bureau des tournages
ils ont réussi à avoir une série de la
bbc qui maintenant tourner depuis sept
ans en guadeloupe et qui permet de faire
des tous les techniciens guadeloupéens
mais également antillais pour venir
travailler en guadeloupe donc c est
totalement possible en martinique d'où
boot est destinée à concourir dans les
festivals du monde entier à commencer
par cannes peut être l'an prochain
cent mille euros ont été investis pour
sa réalisation et les sociétés de
production qui le soutiennent l'ex gaspé
chrono prod espère le vendre pour
diffusion à une grande chaîne nationale